while the seventh annual Second Chance
5K is being held this Saturday at
Gibbons Elementary School Holly Weaver
and Jenny Slater co-founders of the Run
both of them lost sisters to opioid
abuse well now they share their
experiences and what we can do as a
community to help
we are trying to bridge the communities
in Las Vegas
to one another
because the opposite of addiction is not
sobriety right we've learned that the
opposite of addiction is connection
and we're very disconnected
check in for this very popular 5Ks at 8
A.M it's open to all ages all Fitness
levels the run is right near 215 in West
Charleston and it raises awareness for
substance abuse and also support those
who might be impacted at the same time
celebrating those who are in recovery
you can find more information on
8newsnow.com